President Biden has let 6.2 million
illegal aliens into the United States
according to data from the Congressional
budget office Biden l in 1.2 million
illegal aliens in the first year then
upped it to 2.7 million in the second
year and then hit a whopping 3.3 million
this past year just through October
which means the final number for last
year will inevitably M be much much
higher if the illegals that Biden alone
let in over just 3 years were to form
form their own state it would be the
18th most populous state in the Union a
state formed of just Joe Biden's illegal
aliens would be 7% larger than Wyoming
Vermont Alaska North Dakota South Dakota
Delaware and Rhode Island combined we
are witnessing an historic illegal
Invasion being conducted with the
approval and encouragement of the
president of the United States and his
entire Administration